okay as we so often do we're going to
understand today's new idea in the light
of an idea that we met very recently and
we're going to build on that foundation
okay so when we first introduced the
idea of integration we said you would
have an integral you've got some
function and you know what its graph
looks like
if you want to compare it to the x-axis
you're interested in an area there is
gonna start somewhere it's going to end
somewhere based on these x-values how do
I describe where it starts and where it
ends what do I do to this yeah okay
I'm gonna put two numbers here which we
call boundaries so I would say a and B
now I'm not sure if I've mentioned this
a bit of nomenclature before but these
things boundaries there's one which is
at the top the ending and then there's
one down the bottom which is where you
start so we call this the upper boundary
or the upper bound and we call this guy
the lower boundary or the lower bound
now I want to I want to get to this
question of what happens with this when
we don't have boundaries
now that doesn't make sense in terms of
the original definition when you think
about well how can you have an area if
there's no like end here and and there
does just go on forever for instance if
I said here's the x-squared curve and I
didn't give you a beginning and an end
right then you'd say well I don't know
this just sort of goes on forever it
doesn't have a value okay which is why
when you don't supply these boundaries
since there is no definite value to this
you know it equals 8 or equals 15 pi or
some number it has no definite value so
we call it an indefinite integral so as
an example and I'll stay with this color
if I want to talk about indefinite
integrals as opposed to definite
integrals okay
what's the comparison well first they
look ever so slightly different in that
there are no boundaries so let's just
give an example let's go say X DX okay
so this is indefinite as compared to
let's put something in here the integral
of xdx
from 1 to 2 ok so you can see all right
what's the difference the difference is
that you see boundaries or you don't see
boundaries okay now let's have a look at
this because we know how to do this part
right what is my next step what do I
have to work out here I'm going to work
out the primitive of the what's that
thing called inside the thing we're
integrating the integrand so I'm going
to look at the integrand find its
primitive and because this is a nice
easy function you can tell me straight
off what the primitive is it's x squared
on 2 so I put that in big square back
brackets for what reason
what am I going to do with this
primitive I'm going to I'm going to do
some evaluation and some subtraction
right with those same boundaries I had
before I'm gonna substitute them in and
then I'm gonna get some numbers out ok
so I mean this is actually quite easy to
do let's do it I'm gonna get 4 on to
take away 1 on 2 so this is 1 and 1/2
you okay with that
now remember how over these past couple
days I've been trying to get the very
subtle distinction between area and an
integral area and an integral very
closely connected but not identical so
see here listed integral its value as 1
and 1/2 is 1 and 1/2 an area the answer
is not yet right if I wanted an area I'd
need some I need some units like is at 1
and 1/2 square centimeters square meters
square kilometers on a Cartesian plane
you've got no units like that so you
would say for example the area
is one and a half and then you do to
really say square units because you
don't have centimeters or inches or
whatever provided so whatever units they
are okay please note the integral itself
is just a number
the area has area units on it okay now
then that brings us over to here what do
we do with this thing if we don't have
any boundaries if we don't get to a
number a definite integral just gives
you a value at the end when we say an
indefinite integral what we really mean
is that it's again about that primitive
function okay but since I'm not
evaluating it do you remember when we
were finding the premiere function
earlier on before you knew there was
such a thing as an integral I said you
need to include something extra on the
premiere if you remember what that was
it was plus C why is there a plus C here
yeah no there's a constant but that
leads me to the next question which is
why do I have to put a constant here
okay so this constant here could be 1 or
negative 8 or 100 and when I
differentiate I'll still come back to X
yes so this guy here is the primitive
now why didn't I include a plus C here
do you remember the reason I didn't need
to include it yeah yeah see this step
here there we a plus C here plus e there
it'll disappear it doesn't matter okay
but now that I'm not doing that
subtraction step now that I'm not doing
that evaluation I have to bring the plus
C back and now at last since we're in
this topic I can tell you what this
thing is actually called it is called
the constant of what processes we just
done have we just what process have we
just done this is integration this is
the constant of integration I couldn't
call it that before because you didn't
know integration was the thing but now
you do okay so indefinite integral
versus a definite integral a definite
integrals just the number you go through
you conjure it you subtract and then you
get a value at the end the indefinite
integral is more
exactly the same thing as a primitive
function it's in fact it's another way
like you will actually stop hearing
about the primitive function now that
you know what an indefinite integral is
we don't use this idea of primitive
function very much once we've got the
the more common way of saying it okay so
when you see indefinite integral or when
you see an integral and there are no
boundaries like here then what you
should basically be thinking of is find
the premiere formal ok all right before
I move on to the next thing does I know
any questions on that so far that's ok
not sure huh all right let me make it a
quick note about marking because I will
inevitably get this question you might
not be thinking about right now but some
time in the next nine months you will
think of it and now you will know the
answer all of you ok what happens if I
don't include the plus C what happens if
I get given an indefinite integral and I
don't write plus C on the end it's a
very common error ok if you are lucky
nothing will happen because we get that
you've done the main thing which is fine
the primitive and that can be quite hard
these are easy functions I've
deliberately giving you a nice simple
one but some of the integrals you'll get
later they are they take a lot of work
ok and it'd be a shame like oh my
goodness plus C it's such a little thing
on the end it's not nearly as important
as this ok but it is still important can
you take off your student hat for a
second and put on your teacher hat why
do you think it matters that you see
your students writing plus C what
difference does it make ok so there's a
concept to be understood let me push on
that a little bit further what is the
concept I want you to picture two
students one student always puts the
plus C and another one doesn't even know
that there is such a thing as plus C and
never therefore writer what is the
different thing that's understood or not
understood between these two students
that's a hard question what do you think
hmm you want to hazard something here I
think this is the basic idea the idea is
that when you differentiate something
right there is one derivative and only
one derivative okay but when you
integrate something they are actually a
multiplicity of different primitives and
that is a key concept that's like a
really important conceptual idea and
we're looking for you to articulate that
understanding by writing plus C which
means it in the final HSC exam where
you'll encounter sort of maybe eight to
ten on a rough estimate eight to ten
indefinite integrals right they're not
going to ping you for a mark every time
you miss plus C because that would be
unfair it is a small thing and to lose
eight marks on plus C that's a big deal
we don't do that okay but there will be
a single question in these if I can
guarantee it I'll put money down okay
where the question like it'll be an
Internet and definite integral I know
what quite simple but it'll be worth two
marks can you tell me what those two
marks are for one for the primitive and
one for the plus C and you need both of
them right and so on that particular
question if you didn't put plus C there
yes you will lose an entire mark and we
do the same thing in our internal exams
okay so someone's gonna ask me later on
like or you can lose mark on this well
now you know the answer okay